[Music]
let's go to caroline in
philadelphia where i was born and raised
what's up caroline
hi how are you
probably the best ever i probably
overstated that i'm cool how about you
i'm doing well and i'm hoping you can
help me there is a small to quite small
chance that i can help but i will give
my best shot what's up okay
well here's my situation i am fat
and i know it's not a
knowledge problem it's a behavior
problem
okay and things have gotten way worse
since the pandemic started
and so it's like a stress it's i guess
stress binge
and i need that
okay how long have you so let me back up
you said i'm fat with a
a
period at the end of that sentence a
declarative statement
was that a hard thing to say out loud or
is that a thing that brings you shame or
did you have to work your way up to say
that like walk me through that how do
you see yourself
um
so i think
originally
there was a certain amount of i didn't
believe it was happening or there was
excuses for it
like what and
well
i guess before i would say things like i
have this i have an endocrine disorder
which makes it hard to lose weight or
i'd have excuses about i've got two kids
and i'm busy and what i realized is that
i think my first step is to be kind of
radically accountable for it
and then try and move on from there
okay
so going back to
radical radical
accountability what does that mean
well so right now i'm five foot two okay
and i'm 244 pounds as of today
and in that has a doctor ever has a
doctor had diagnosed you as as morbidly
obese
um yeah or i'm right there okay okay
yeah and how long have you wrestled with
this
um
i mean i'll say this i've been
you know i've kind of flirted with the
200 pound line
for about 10 years where i was just
under that and
and then the pandemic happened
and then i crossed that line okay and i
feel like mentally i realized that
this is something that um and then i got
covered really bad and i had a friend
die of covid who was also had a weight
problem
and i realized i really really need to
take this seriously yeah
there's some terrifying data with
obesity and antibody it's there's some
yeah there's some really remarkable
research out there on the
correlation between
um
hard code hitting people hard and
obesity so
hey can i tell you this
i tell you i'm really freaking proud of
you for saying
no more
like i gotta i gotta i gotta take this
serious
that's hard
yeah
like no i'm serious that's a hard thing
to do because you know
what most do statistically
is they look to their left and the right
they go ah sucks to be them
and they just keep plugging along
it is hard to have a never again moment
most people never do it
how
is this a story you were born into is
this a story somebody started telling
you back in the day or your parents big
and what i'm trying to do is
work is this a lifestyle thing is this a
work thing is this an addiction
is this a
um
i got a bunch of genetic work back um a
month ago with my doctor i have a
genetic they call it the cookie jar gene
and he said this is from my doctor the
guy's incredible i'm gonna have him on
the show he said if you open a package
of whatever
the chances that you can grit your teeth
and will power through it are very very
small at the genetic level
and so like my wife i think i've talked
about on the show she's a serial killer
because she can buy a bag of oreos and
just eat one and then eat one like a
five or six days later and i also think
she eats children i don't know how any
human can do that
if i open a bag of cookies i will eat
the entire thing that day because i love
them and so what he was telling me was
your
your
road through life
will be avoidance
you will not willpower your way through
this does that make so what i'm trying
to get at with you is is this narrative
a part of your life
is this a
did this happen after a trauma did this
happen
your parents were big did like where
what's the roots here
so i wouldn't say my parents are big
they're they're not i think what
happened is i was a chubby kid
um and then i became a thin teenager a
thin 20 something
and then around 30
things just
i i think what i realized is you know i
can
maybe it's avoidance like you're talking
about it's i will i will meal prep on
sunday and have the perfectly portioned
breakfast and lunch
and then around this time
i get home from you know work i pick up
my kids from daycare i'm making dinner
for everybody like and then all of a
sudden i'll turn around and they won't
even remember necessarily
that i ate
my dinner and maybe the rest of my kids
dinner
and maybe there were two glasses of wine
and i i won't even be conscious of it
yeah
and it's like i'll be so regimented
on so many things and then it's like it
just kind of unravels
usually when i have a lot to do and i'm
stressed out
so walk me through stress for you
what are you stressed from um
well i'm a working mom
and i have two kids who are daycare age
my son's five and my daughter's just
almost two yeah
and you know i'm in a dual income
household
and you know it's like we just
work you know we work and the kids get
sick and then you come home and you hit
like second shift of everything yeah
and and it's just i won't even
necessarily sit down when this happened
what keeps you up i'm trying to get
everything done
what keeps you up at night like if you
had to tell me two or three things that
freak you out what are they
um
getting it all done i guess being behind
like i never feel like i'm caught up
yeah
never
you know right now even like i'm so
excited for this phone call and all i
can think about is the 20 things i have
to do of course
after it
before bedtime
and then
like i don't have like it's just a
season of life that's just very
stressful and then add the pandemic and
i feel like
like a lot of working moms it all got
thrown on us it did but caroline this
isn't a season
this is a long time
this is years
yeah and this is
a
worthy incredible woman
who is trying to chase down value
like with all you have
to the point that
at certain at certain times of the day
your body disassociates itself from you
from reality
so that it can cope
and then it plugs back in and when the
lights come back on we're just in a
shame spiral and a exhaustion spiral and
we collapse we do the whole thing over
again the next day and the next day and
the next day
yeah
and so
what manifests itself as oh my gosh i
gained 50 pounds in two years what the
what happened
that's a that's a piece of a story
that's been being told for a long time
fair yeah how's your marriage
i mean we're doing i mean we're doing
well honestly it's we had my second
daughter
and then i felt like it was it just was
so much more work like when it was one
kid divided by two parents we did okay
and then it was two kids and then
everybody was home
and
you know we lost all our help
and i kind of realized how much
that help
i it yeah
yeah
so
there's a lot here and i i'm
it's way outside my lane
to talk about this level of
obesity on on like that's just that's
beyond my expertise ten ten lanes over
okay
have you partnered with a doctor before
um
not
not
radically okay so doctors have talked to
me about it yes weight watchers you know
yeah yeah yeah
so here's where i want you to start
and as we as we get to
um this show will air
we're doing this between thanksgiving
and christmas so for the listener but
this show will air around new year's
where i want you to start with this is
not on how do i quit snacking or
overeating
this is a much bigger conversation
and i want it to start with an identity
conversation
who am i
and you started this call by saying i'm
fat
i would tell you
that's a physical characteristic
that's not an identity
and some would look at people who are
overweight and say they're lazy that's
an identity
some would say that person's got a lot
going on
both psychologically spiritually
emotionally physically they've got a lot
that person's exhausted
that person doesn't have resources that
like whatever identities you want to put
in there
but i'm fat isn't i not an identity
okay
what i've had to do in my life and again
i've never faced anything like what
you're facing okay
and so let's be honest you got a hard
road to hoe because you're not just
losing weight you're changing who you
are from the inside out
i had to when i made some pretty drastic
changes
i had to decide
i am a guy
who will be a good steward of my one
precious little body
and before that i had to decide i'm a
guy
who is worth taking care of
and then behaviors and choices and
decisions all stemmed from those things
i am a guy who's worthy of my wife's
love i'm a guy who's
gonna roll around on the floor with my
kids
going to last longer than they can in a
wrestling match
and that's an iden that's the kind of
guy i want to be
and so then i had to create a world what
did that mean for me i had to get really
serious with a medical doctor i had to
get really serious with my mental health
i'd get really serious with
a workout regimen and a daily routine
and all these other things but i didn't
start with those things
most people go wrong as they say i want
to lose 100 pounds
and you can lose 100 pounds but you'll
go with you
hear them saying that same exhausted mom
will just be you 100 pounds lighter and
you'll have shifted to a fifth glass of
wine or to somebody at work or to
another netflix you're just going to
keep passing that around you get what
i'm saying
yeah
i'd love to see you value yourself so
much that you would go get radical with
the doctor
i would love to see you value yourself
so much
that you go get radical with a
workout program with a with a personal
trainer
whatever that is i don't even care what
the program is it could just be jumping
i don't care what it is
anybody who tells you like this is the
one idiots idiots whatever one you'll do
right i don't care okay
i wish you would get so radical with
your heart
and your value and your worth on this
planet and to your husband and to your
kids into your neighborhood into your
workplace
that you would say these things won't be
in my home that's what we have to do in
my house when i'm out of town my my wife
has
like
they call them like gluten tuesdays or
whatever i mean they'll get pizzas and
stuff when i'm gone because that's the
only time i can survive in the home and
all my other kids and their little
rational decision-making or whatever
brains they got i didn't get that
and so we just can't have it in the
house and we all live with it and it's
all good it's cool and we've just made
peace with it and life's great
and if there is marshmallows in the
house i'm gonna eat most of the bag i
just am i'm gonna just dominate it it's
cool
uh when we have people over we send
leftovers home with them
just to get this right but again it's
about a radical way of living and that's
where you're at but the radical living
starts underneath a new identity
so my question for you caroline is
are you worth being well
yes
do you believe that
90
nope where's that other 10
um
who told you you're not worth being well
somebody told you yeah who
i think it's just being like saying like
mom comes after kids
no
that's yeah that is a modern myth of a
live a nonsense of
trash
if you don't take care of you first
you've got nothing left for those kids
yeah
right
and you're worth being well so are those
kids
would you do me a huge favor
yes
would you be willing to walk with me for
the next year
and check in with us
yeah i'll do that because here's what's
gonna happen either you're gonna come on
the air and say i just screw it
and if you do that i'll high-five you
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna shame
you i'm not gonna get on to you
um that'll be as real as real can be
or you're gonna make some radical
identity shifts
and decide that you're worth it not just
in spirit only but a full hundred
percent and you're gonna make some
radical behavior choices you're gonna
make some hard phone calls
you're gonna tell your husband you're
gonna tell some of your friends you're
gonna say
this is the year this stops
i'm getting it all back
every bit of it my zest for life my
laughter i'm not gonna live my life
exhausted i'm not gonna live my life 150
pounds overweight i'm not gonna i'm not
whatever those things are
and then i'm gonna go get the i'm gonna
go
lean into the resources that are gonna
make that stuff happen you can't do this
one on your own and you gotta go see a
medical doctor asap okay you promised me
that
i promised that okay you're worth that
and i want you to be as vulnerable with
them as you were with me
okay do you promise
yeah okay
have you ever listened to the show
before
all the time
okay you got to get some better podcasts
in your feed by the way
i mean for real let's be honest
okay one thing about the show is i never
lie to people okay
do you trust me
i trust you you're worth being well
okay okay that's cool man
let's go let's go get some beers
i'm serious i'm just processing i know i
know you are i know you are so here's
the here's your your homework tonight
and then i want you to email it to me
tomorrow okay
okay
okay let's get some beers
he's just processing it
um here's your homework i want you to
write down five new identity statements
okay
okay
and they're gonna start with i am
and they're not gonna be physical
characteristics they're gonna be
they're gonna be aspirational identities
here's who i'm gonna become in 2022.
okay five of them cool
that sounds good fair
i think that's fair promise i can do it
i promise tomorrow i 100
believe in you 100
think this is the year
and anybody listen to this whose life
went sideways the last 24 months you're
not crazy and you're not broken
the world went sideways it still is
sideways it's still spinning sideways
the choices
our life is now
and then what
we all woke up today with this is what
we've got this is what the choices we've
made this is the decisions we haven't
made this is where we are this is what's
been done to us this is the stories we
were born into these are the stories
we've been told and these are the
stories i tell myself i'm fat i'm broke
i'm dumb i'm filling the blank i suck at
i cheated i fill in the blank whatever
it is
own that story
and then the world is waiting for you to
answer the next one which is now what
now we're gonna do
the whole world's waiting what are you
gonna do next
caroline i'm rooting for you
we all are rooting for you not a lot of
people listening to the show let's be
honest
just 27 28
actually i got the new numbers dang
there's a lot of people that's in the
show james
it's a lot it makes me uncomfortable so
i just say 17 because i have low
self-esteem caroline's a lot of people
listen to the show and we're all rooting
for you
we're going to walk alongside you this
year we're going to check in with you
every month or so and i look forward to
having this phone call a year from now
oh my gosh what a different world it's
going to be